- [Moshe] Hey, this
is Moshe Kasher.
- [Natasha] And Natasha Leggero.
- [Moshe] We just got
married six months ago.
- [Natasha] Which we
think pretty much makes us
qualified to give love
advice to strangers.
- [Moshe] So,
that's what we did.
We packed up the
car, hit the road,
and spread the love.
- [Moshe And Natasha] This
is the Honeymoon Tour.
- Look how much
better my boots look.
- [Natasha] Yeah.
- Bought some boot-cleaning
solution today here in Portland.
- Wait, Moshe, you should
do that thing where, like,
no woman jerks off to feet.
- We were trying to work
on a joke about that.
- There's no woman who's
like, needs to come on
some man's feet.
- Right, the fetish.
Although women do have fetishes.
- Not feet.
- No.
- [Natasha] No.
- Are there any female
foot fetishists?
- No way.
I bet you there's
zero in the world.
(jazzy music)
- Do you guys need a ticket?
- [Woman] No, nuh-uh.
- Do you have a friend
who might need a ticket?
I'm trying to sell this ticket
because my husband's sick.
One ticket, 15
dollars and a beer.
That's all I want.
- I heard you have
a ticket for sale.
- I do.
My husband got sick, he
wouldn't even eat the tacos
I brought him for dinner.
- Can we call him?
- Yes.
(phone ringing)
- He's probably vomiting
right now or something.
- [Man] Hello?
- Hi, is this Kelly?
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Hey Kelly, it's Moshe
Kasher and Natasha Leggero.
Say hi Natasha.
- Hi, we're really embarrassed
your wife is trying to
sell your ticket at our show.
- Yeah, we were wondering, we
know you aren't feeling well,
but we wondering if you
could maybe talk her
out of doing this.
- So the host of a
relationship expertise show,
Mr. Greg Behrendt.
Greg, if you want to come out.
Hey, there he is.
- So we've been married
for seven years.
Christie once wore JNCOs.
- JNCOs are a style of
pant originally started
by a family called the
JNCO family in Florence.
The progenitor of Salvatore
JNCO first created
harlequin pants and clown
pants for the opera and then
he actually came over to
America where his son carried
on the family loom.
Finally, in 1991 when
Frankie Bones and some other
sick fucking DJ
started the rave scene.
This is a pretty happy
couple, if that's the
worst problem they have.
Give them a round of applause.
- I think there's
people out there who
really need our help.
- Anybody want to
come up with a real
Come on up!
- So, Willow, what is your
main problem with Danny
that you'd like to discuss,
and then he can say
his with you?
- Let me say the problem.
- There we go, yeah.
Yes, I love it.
- I got the problem.
The problem is me.
The problem is sometimes,
this morning, she was
putting on some shorts dude,
and I was like, are you
going to wear those, cause
I'd rather you didn't,
- Wait, is this what
- Stop telling me that I
look good because it makes
me feel bad and I'm like
fuck, I'm scared that you're
going to go out without
me and get raped.
- Oh.
This has been a
great comedy show.
- You are amazing, I love you.
And I love you too.
I've seen you at the
Hawthorne Theatre.
- What about this guy
who's been staring
at us the whole time?
- Yeah, I don't know.
- What the heck is going on?
- You want, here, you want
it for fifteen dollars?
- It's half the
price of what I paid.
- Give me the cash.
- [Moshe] Are you
really going to come?
We're the comedians.
- [Woman] They're really funny.
- And we're very famous,
we're household names.
- You're gonna come?
But she needs fifteen dollars.
- Yeah, no problem.
- Okay.
All right, thank you.
- Appreciate it.
- So it's not the same
problem that they had where
he doesn't like her z
pant, what are they called?
- JNCOs.
But your problem is that you
want her to wear some JNCOs?
- You're struggling
with some real issues,
some real self-esteem
stuff, because that's not
about her that's about the
sadness inside of you man.
You're just afraid you're
going to lose her, period, so
that means you don't feel
good enough about yourself
inside the relationship,
sorry, I'm great at this.
- He is great at this.
- I'm just, I'm
fucking great at it.
- What do you think?
- I didn't want to be, I
wanted to be in a band.
- I'd like to play
devil's advocate.
I think that Willow, scoot
over, I feel that Willow
could do a little bit better
job letting Danny know
how sexy he is and how
manly he is and how
attracted to him you are
and he needs to be a bit
more confident.
- And realize that not every
man is a creep like you
and that your love
is good enough.
- Your love is beautiful.
- Will you guys commit to it?
- Absolutely.
- Yeah all right.
- That's the end of
their relationship.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Willow and Danny!
(audience cheers)
- I want Greg to help someone
else he's so good at it.
- Oh, he is good at it.
Maybe we should have him do us.
- Oh, I don't want
to go down that path.
Oh no, I like you guys,
I want to stay friends.
- So you want me to say
what my problem is with you?
- Go for it.
- He's real messy.
Like when he drops something,
he told me his instinct
is to run away from it.
So that's like a whole
household of stuff that he's
running away from.
- Do you want me to handle
that one or is there?
- That's the only problem.
- The little tiny shit,
they're just seeds
and then they grow, trust me.
So like, hear that, and
start packing your shit up,
I'm telling you.
It'll wreck it.
The dumbest thing.
- That's your advice?
- In a relationship,
that's an easy compromise.
If you really love a
person, you'll do the thing
they want you to do and not
the thing you prefer to do.
Does that make sense?
- It's not that big of
a deal though Moshe.
- My turn.
- No, I think we're done.
- One thing that I don't
like, is that, basically,
like, she's not
faithful to me I guess.
- You know you're going
to have to get over that.
People have their own
lives and they have
to be who they are.
You know, pick up your
shit and let her do
what she feels like.
- Thank you.
- It's going to save your
marriage I swear to God.
- You guys, thank you
so much for coming out.